I have to confess that I'm not a fan of sew-as-you-go, except maybe for blankets.
But I was recently studying a vintage
pattern book and the light bulb came on.
Now, if you aren't familiar with sew-as-you-go,
one piece is knitted
and removed from the machine.
As you knit the next piece,
you hang the outside edge of that first
piece on the edge stitch of the piece
you're knitting. When you're done,
the pieces are joined
with no extra finishing.
But here's the light bulb moment.
I've knit my first piece and I've
cast-on for the second piece.
With the purl side facing,
I'll pick up the edge of the first piece
and hang it on the third
needle that's in work.
Knit over and back.
Pick up the next loop and hang
it on the third needle.
Over and back and continue.
Now, I know this looks odd.
Hang in there with me,
I'll continue picking up and knitting.
When I get to the end, I'll hang
the final loop before binding off.
This creates a nice corded or felled look.
Remember, flat-felled seams
and sewing like jeans seams?
We're taking advantage of the Stockinette
curl and creating a nice
texture for our garment.
Can you think of someplace
you could use this technique?